i kid you not this is the headline from
the la times
larry elder
is the black face of white supremacy
[Applause]
thank you all for coming why power our
pal larry elder
looking pretty good in this recall
election in california
we've been talking about the recall for
a long time there's this effort for
years building up now to recall gavin
newsom because he was a terrible
governor
i say with personal first-hand
experience of what a horrible governor
he is i fled the state in part because
of his poor leadership
so there were these
people who were trying to replace him
you had kevin faulconer down there in
san diego
i guess a good republican but he just
didn't have the name recognition or the
fundraising ability john cox had already
gotten beaten by by newsome same thing
didn't really raise money didn't have
name recognition
bruce jenner that who's not
really conservative in any meaningful
sense of the term right he said i don't
have any loyalty to the republicans i
don't have any loyalty to trump i'm
mostly focused on the lgbt emphasis on
the t community
to say nothing of the fact that
he clearly has a tenuous relationship
with reality on very basic questions so
that wasn't going to work that was
always a distraction republicans didn't
really support him
and then larry elder came in larry elder
a little more libertarian than i would
like in my sort of candidate i mean he's
much more libertarian i think than
conservative but he's got some strong
conservative stances i like the guy
pretty straight shooter he would be an
extraordinarily great improvement in
california and and here's what's crucial
he actually has a shot
the way i know he's got a shot
is that the left is taking him really
seriously the way i know he's really got
a shot
is that the left is now calling him a
white supremacist
that's how you know that you you've got
a really strong republican candidate is
when someone who has never been accused
or never been involved in you know
racial terrible things when just out of
the blue
he gets called a white supremacist even
in the case of larry elder if he's a
black guy so
i kid you not this is the headline from
the la times
larry elder
is the black face of white supremacy
you've been warned
he's the black face-up don't
don't let his black skin
his upbringing in south central fool you
no no he's a
white supremacist is it even worth
trying to read this article
i don't i don't think so here's one i
won't lie right this person few things
infuriate me more than watching a black
person use willful blindness and
cherry-picked facts to make overly
simplistic arguments that whitewash
the complex problems that come along
with being black in america
few things delight me more than watching
libs
rend their garments and gnash their
teeth when they face a serious challenge
from a conservative especially in this
case a black conservative because the
they'll call anyone a white supremacist
i mean they call trump a white
supremacist
if i if i ever run for anything i'm sure
they'll call me a white supremacist
despite my swarthiness they call
everyone a white supremacist
hitler neo-nazi they did it to reagan
they do it to everybody
but it's really funny when they do it to
a black guy right because it's so
preposterous good this is good news for
larry elder
i mean he's
he's doing very well in the polls the
polls are a little weird on this race
because the only poll that really
matters if you're larry elder is whether
you recall or you don't recall
because there's the first question on
the ballot is do you want to recall
newsome yes or no
the next question is who do you want to
replace him larry elder is trouncing
everyone else in the in the who do you
want to replace him part right now so
the only question that matters is yes or
no
if 50 plus one voters say yes
then he's recalled
if
more voters say no
he's not recalled but if he's recalled
larry elder almost certainly will be the
governor
stop
don't go don't leave me i need you i
need you to go to apple podcasts or
spotify or google play or stitcher or
whatever whatever you wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show
click
subscribe
then wait for that to populate in your
feed maybe leave it a five-star review
if you don't mind and leave a comment
right here and say hello to me on
youtube we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]